[موسيقى]
مساء الخير استاذ في دراسات الشرق الادنى
ركزت معظم كتاباتي على التاريخ الفكري
والسياسي والاجتماعي في الشرق الاوسط
وبشكل خاص على الدول شبه الجزيره العربيه
كتب مطولا عن الثقافتين
وعن السياسات السعوديه واليمنيه وحركتي
الوهابيه والسلفيه وجوانب العقيده ايضا
والشريعه الاسلاميتين برنارد هيكل مدير
المعهد عبر الاقليمي للدراسات المعاصره
حول الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا واسيا
الوسطى في جامعه في امريكا في سؤال مباشر
دكتور برنارد اهلا وسهلا فيك معي في سؤال
مباشر
مرحبا شكرا استاذ خالد دكتور خليني ابدا
معك يعني انت مهتم كثير بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه والتحولات التي حاصله فيها وكتبت
في 2015 كتاب حول التغيير الاجتماعي
والسعودي والاقتصادي المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في مرحله انتقاليه
وتكررت زيارتك للسعوديه بشكل كبير يمكن
خلال السنوات القليله الماضيه
هذه الزيارات هل هي في اطار يعني كتابي
بحثي بحكم دراستك للمنطقه اما هناك يعني
اسباب او مهام اخرى
لا لا انا اكاديمي وانا على وشك من
الانتهاء من كتاب جديد عن تاريخ المملكه
تاريخ السياسي والثقافي في المملكه فلذلك
يعني اتردد دائما
للمملكه لمقابله شخصيات مختلفه
واصدقاء بالاضافه الى زياره المكتبات
دائره الملك عبد العزيز مثلا وبعد المكتب
الوطنيه وبعض المكتبات في الجامعيه فلا
تردداتي كلها يعني في مجال البحث العلمي
البحث الاكاديمي كتاب جديد عن ايش عن
السعوديه من اي ناحيه دكتور
عن السعوديه نعم نعم عن تاريخ السعوديه
السياسي والثقافي والاجتماعي من
اجتياح العراقي للكويت يعني من تقريبا
1990 الى الان الى اليوم وشو يميزوا عن
كتاب
رؤى حول التغيير الاجتماعي والسياسي
والاقتصادي للمملكه العربيه السعوديه في
مرحله انتقاليه في نفس الاطار ولا في جديد
يعني
اغلب اغلب الكتب اغلب الكتب التي كتبت عن
المملكه عن تاريخ المملكه في يعني في
العقود هذه الاخيره كانت اكثرها يعني
اهتماماتها اما
موضوع الاسلام السياسي والاسلاميين او
الحركات الاسلاميه والصحوه او يعني بحوث
لها علاقه بالاقتصاد والنفط فانا انا
كتابي مختلف يعني
ما هو عن لا عن الاسلاميه اكيد الموضوع
موضوع الصحوه داخل داخل في الكتاب بس يعني
انا رؤيتي
في التاريخ المملكه اوسع
ويدخل
مثلا
المفكرين
وطنيين
بعض الناس يسمونهم الوطنجية
بالاضافه الى تاريخ الاسره
والعلاقات مع الدول المجاوره والدول
والسياسات الدوليه منها امريكا والصين
فيعني انا انا كتابي اوسع وما هو منحصر لا
بالاسلام السياسي ولا بالوهابيه ولا
بالنفط يعني اوسع بكثير من ذلك ليش عن
السعوديه
بتحديدا تكتب دكتور برنارد
اول شيء يعني انا عندي حب للبلد وهوس في
البلد وتاريخ البلد لانه بلد يعني مثير
جدا من ناحيه العلميه والثقافيه وبعدين
اضافه الى ذلك لما لم تعطى السعوديه حقها
في الدراسات الاكاديميه والدراسات العلميه
يعني اغلب الكتب التي كتبت عن الشرق
الاوسط اغلبها اما عن مصر او عن سوريا او
عن لبنان
والعراق مؤخرا بسبب بسبب الاجتياح
الامريكي للعراق فالمملكه يعني في بعض
الكتب بس يعني مكتبه المكتبه عن تاريخ
المملكه صغيره جدا يعني مقارنه بالدول
الاخرى في الشرق الاوسط البعض يتهمك بانه
انت منحاز للسعوديه دكتور في كتاباتك
وانت جزء من حمله تسويق مقصوده للسعوديه
خاصه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وكذلك في الدول الغربيه بشكل عام شو رايك
فيها الكلام دكتور
لا انا يعني انا اولا اكاديمي
واحاول بكتاباتي انه يكون موضوعي يعني في
طرحي فعندي انتقادات لبعد السياسات في بعد
سياسات المملكه وعندي بعد
يعني طرح
بيمدح بعد السياسات كذلك يعني في المملكه
انا يعني انا لست من حازا يعني الاولا لا
لي علاقه
بالدوله السعوديه الماليه او او بالدوله
الامريكيه حتى يعني ما عندي انا اكاديمي
بموضوعيه بس ما بخفي عنك اني بحب البلد
وعندي اصدقاء في البلد
واتمنى يعني الخير للمملكه مثل ما اتمنى
الخير يعني للمنطقه كلها وبالاضافه الى
ذلك انا امريكي يعني جنسيتي امريكيه
ومصالح امريكيه مهمه بالنسبه لي وارى انه
الاستقرار والازدهار في العالم العربي
بصبي بمصلحه امريكا تحب اللي يحبك كمان يا
دكتور خليني اسالك انت التقيت بالامير
محمد
محمد بن سلمان اي نعم اكيد قابلت الامير
محمد وامراه اخرى يعني عده مرات شو اللي
لفت نظرك في شخصيه الامير محمد بن سلمان
في لقاءاتك مع دكتور
شخصيه كاريزماتيه يعني هو شخص اولا
اول مره
قابلته ذكرني بالرئيس الامريكي اللي هو
يعني سياسي مخضره عنده عنده امكانيه انه
يحسس الشخص اللي بيتكلم معاه انه مهم فهذه
يعني خصله مهمه عندك كاريزماتيه بالاضافه
الى يعني طاقه
يعني طاقه خارقه او او كبيره جدا
عندما يتكلم عن رؤيته للبلد والتغييرات في
البلد انا ما عندي بصراحه شك انه هو
اهتمامه بالبلد وطموحه للبلد
يعني منبعه
يعني عنده يعني عنده
نيه خالصه وصادقه انه بده يحسن بلده بده
يطور بلده وبده يدافع عن مصالح بلده
كيف وجدت التغييرات اللي حصلت في السعوديه
دكتور من
2015 منذ الاعلان عن الرؤيه الى اليوم
يعني
ليك انا بقولها دائما في امريكا انه لو في
2010 مثلا
قلت لي انه بتحصل التغييرات هذه
التغييرات خاصه الاجتماعيه اللي حصلت كنت
بقول لك بال 2010 انه بتحصل حرب اهليه في
البلد يعني هذه تغييرات كبيره جدا ولكن
والحمد لله يعني انه ما حصل ما حصل عنف ما
حصلت حرب اهليه البلد تطور وتغير دكتور
خليني نذهب معك يمكن الان الى ما حصل
مؤخرا في السعوديه وفي المنطقه بشكل عام
من تحولات سياسيه مهمه
خاصه الاتفاق السعودي الايراني
المصالحه مع بشار الاسد عوده سوريا الى
جامعه الدول العربيه
الحاله اللي ممكن توصيفها بانها تصفير
للمشاكل معالجه او تهدئه ربما لحاله
التوتر الغليان اللي كانت موجوده في
المنطقه كنت اتصور مثلا انه في يوم من
الايام تتفق السعوديه مع ايران خلينا نقول
يعني على الاقل في هذا التوقيت الان هي
مساله المفاوضات اخذت وقت بين بين الطرفين
لكن تتوقع انه كانت تتم في هذا الوقت الان
الامر مفاجاه يعني
انا انا انا انا نظرتي نظرتي للمصالحه هذه
الاخيره هي انه
الامر الاساسي بالنسبه للسعوديه هو بناء
البلد
والرؤيه رؤيه 2030
ما ممكن انه الامير محمد
الدوله السعوديه تبني وتغير الاقتصاد
البلد من دون ما يكون في امن امان
والصواريخ هذه اللي تطلق من ايران وتطلق
من من اليمن وتهبط على السعوديه يعني ما
ممكن الواحد يبني بلد صحيح وانت في حاله
حرب اما مع ايران او مع جماعه ايران في
اليمن او في غير او في العراق فمن المهم
انه يحصل امان ويحصل امن في البلد
فاللي شفته انه الامير محمد حاول يدخل
الصين على الخط في المفاوضات مع
الايرانيين لتقليص او
يعني حصر ايران من من القيام بهذه العمليه
يعني يعني
وضع نوع من من الاطار على الحركات
الايرانيه في المنطقه هذه هذه يعني فيها
نوع من المغامره يعني النظام الايراني لم
يتغير نفس النظام وهل ولكن ربما مع تدخل
الصين لا ربما مع تدخل الصين يمكن يغير
يغير سياساته تجاه المملكه الصين حتى تقنع
الايرانيين بالتغيير في مشروعها دكتور
دوله تستولي على عده عواصم عربيه
لها دور كبير
كيف ممكن تقنع الايرانيين ايه انا انا
الصين اهم دوله بالنسبه لايران من ناحيه
الاقتصاديه الصين عندها عندها مشروع كبير
في مد
الخطوط
والاتصالات الى ايران تعرف اللي بيسموها
البلتون رود
لا عندهم اثر كبير على على القياده
الايرانيه الى وين هل ممكن توقع تنازل
تراجع مثلا من الايرانيين في سوريا على
سبيل المثال في العراق
منشوف الان يعني نحن الان في تجربه في
فتره تجربه تجربه تنشوف اذا الصين لها هذا
الاثر ولا لا خلينا نشوف خليني اتوقف معك
ايضا انا عند فاصل قصير دكتور نعود بعده
للمتابعه في سؤال مباشر
اهلا بكم من جديد في سؤال مباشر ضيفي هو
الدكتور برنارد هيكل الاستاذ دراسات الشرق
الادنى حياك الله دكتور في الجزء الثاني
من البرنامج سؤالي لك عن سوريا وعودتها
الان الى مقعدها في جامعه الدول العربيه
شو اللي تغير وما هي حسابات السعوديه في
عودتها برايك يعني الى الى جامعه الدول
العربيه وعوده العلاقات مع الرياض
يعني
انا اعتقد انه
رياض رياض تريد تهدئه المنطقه عموما تريد
الاستقرار في المنطقه
ربما عوده سوريا لها علاقه
بالاتفاقيه هذه الاخيره مع مع ايران بين
الرياض وطهران
فربما ربما يعني هذا تخمين مني انه ربما
ادخال سوريا في
يعني عوده عوده سوريه الى الى المنطقه
والى الى العالم العربي هو
من ناحيه انه ربما ايران تضغط على
الحوثيون على الحوثيين في اليمن
وتساعد في
تقليص من وطاه وهي ماده الحوثيين خاصه
الضربات هذه اللي كانوا يطلقونها على
المملكه ما اعتقد انه رياض او المملكه
ستساعد سوريا اقتصاديا او ستعطي اموال
لاعاده بناء سوريا هذه كلها
يعني اجراءات
الها علاقه
بالاستقرار
وتهدئه المنطقه
ما هي يعني انه ما تغير رؤيه النظام رؤيه
النظام السوري في في الرياض لم يتغير هل
هي معنيه نظام رياض اليوم في الرياض تريد
بالفعل
اخراج ايران ميليشياتها في المنطقه من
سوريا تحديدا من ضمن الشروط مثلا
لا ما اعتقد ما اعتقد انه الايران الايران
ستخرج جماعتها من سوريا ابدا هي هيمنه على
البلد هذا وهيمنه على لبنان وهيمنه على
العراق يعني
المهم بالنسبه للسعوديه للمملكه هي اليمن
والاردن
يعني لبنان هي مشكله لاسرائيل الغرب اكثر
ما انها مشكله للسعوديه نفس الشيء سوريا
بس هذه الفكره ما تنسف اي محاولات
او
لاعاده العلاقات مع ايران ما زالت متمسكه
بوجود ميليشياتها لتخدم مصالحها في هذه
الدول دكتور واللي تتعارض اكيد مع مصالح
السعوديه ودول اخرى
اكيد يعني
النظام الايراني نظام ثوري يريد اخراج
امريكا من المنطقه يريد ان يهيمن على
المنطقه
من ناحيه من وجهه نظر السعوديه هي انه كيف
تقلص او كيف تحد من حركه ايران
التي تريد ان تزعزع الوضع وتهيمن على
المنطقه
تكتب ما هو الموقف مع امريكا امريكا يعني
يمكن على مضض تقبلت مساله الاتفاق السعودي
الايراني
ولا تريد بالتاكيد ان يكون للصين اي دور
في المنطقه لا من خلال هذه الوساطه ولا من
خلال ايضا حضورها في في في الخليج وتعلم
انه يمكن بعد ما حصل ارسلت مباشره امريكا
غواصه نوويه الى منطقه الخليج في رساله
فهمت على اكثر من شكل يعني خلال فتره
الماضيه الى اي مدى هذا التحرك السعودي
ابر بالعلاقات بين الرياض
العلاقات بين رياض واشنطن هي يعني ما هي
ما هي يعني كويسه يعني فيها في في توتر في
العلاقه خاصه مع الحزب الديمقراطي والرئيس
بايدن
معامله معامله الرئيس بعيدا للسعوديه
الكلام اللي قال له
الطريقه اللي بيتكلم فيها عن السعوديه
وحتى سياساته اتجاه السعوديه وهي انه طلب
من السعوديه انه
الانتاج النفطي يزيد عندما يريد ان
يخفض من سعره اما لضرب ومحاربه روسيا او
لتحسين
الوضع الاقتصادي في امريكا لكي يفوز في
الانتخابات في امريكا يعني علاقته
بالسعوديه ما هي علاقه ما هي علاقه نديه
ما هي علاقه بل هي علاقه فيها نوع من
الاستعلاء فيها نوع من
الاتجاه اتجاه المملكه فا
بالاضافه الى ذلك ان كان بايدن او قبله
ترامب يعني
علاقتهم بالسعوديه تجاه امن الامن القومي
السعودي ما هو يعني ما في ضمانات عندما
ضربت ايران مثلا في سبتمبر 2019 المنشات
النفطيه في السعوديه لم ياتي ترامبو يدافع
لم يفعل شيئا
نفس الشيء يعني نفس الشيء مع بايدن يعني
ما فيها الضمانات من
من
الواقع ومن يعني المنطقي انه السعوديه
عندما تواجه او او تواجه
حاله انه انه الحليف الامريكي لم ياتي ولم
يدافع وكذا انه يوسع علاقاته استراتيجيه
مع دول اخرى من الصين
بريطانيا منها فرنسا منها روسيا انت في
مقابل
في ثمانيه تقول مثلا عن الصحوه نظرت الى
انها لها جانب سياسي مهم وانه السبب
الرئيسي في انتشار الفكر الصحوي في
المنطقه وفي السعوديه تحديدا ما حصل بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه من التقاء مصالح
بين البلدين
وكان لمواجهه الفكر الشيوعي والاتحاد
السوفيتي بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وانتصر يعني في مواجهتهم وفي تدمير ربما
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي ما حصل في
التسعينيات في 91 92 هذا ما قلته دكتور
بالتالي بهذا الشكل هل خاصه ونحن ننظر
اليوم ما يحصل في العالم من حرب روسيا
اوكرانيه داخل فيها امريكا بقوه من خلال
ما تقدمه من دعم على كل المستويات والغرب
بشكل عام هل ستكون السعوديه امريكا يعني
سعيده اليوم لو ما حصلت مثل هذه التغيرات
يعني ببقاء مثل هذه الافكار المتشدده
موجوده
بنفس الاسلوب بنفس السيناريو تتعامل مع
روسيا مثلا او الصين
لا لانه في في في في فرق هائل بين الحرب
البارده اثناء الحرب البارده
الخطر الشيوعي اليساري على امريكا وعلى
المملكه كان واحد يعني كان خطر واحد كان
في في التقاء في المصالح يعني بين بين
المملكه وبين امريكا واضافه الى ذلك دول
اخرى مثل باكستان مثلا الان الان العداء
الامريكي الروسي ما في ما في ايديولوجيه
يعني ما في ما هو خطر مثل خطر الماركسي او
الخطر الشيوعي العداء بين امريكا وبين
الصين كمان ما له علاقه بالايديولوجيا هو
هو
يعني هو صراع على هيمنه اقتصاديه هيمنه في
العالم
فالسعوديه لم تجد تقاطع مصالح ايديولوجيه
مع الولايات المتحده في عدائها للصين او
الغذائها للروس ممتاز
في المملكه مثل مثل دول اخرى يعني مثل حتى
مثل حتى الهند تحاول ان تبقى على حياد من
هذا الصراع وان تستغل الفرص الموجوده في
هذا الصراع لبناء او
ابقاء علاقات مع الطرفين بس المملكه مثلا
علاقاتها الاقتصاديه اكثرها مع الصين ولكن
علاقتها استراتيجيه والعسكريه مع الغرب
فتحاول ان تبقي الطرفين اصدقاء لها
عباره النظام العالمي الجديد تتكرر على
لسان اكثر من مسؤول في كل انحاء العالم
دكتور
سينت تتحدث عن نظام عالمي جديد تلعب فيه
دورا مهما يعني تتحدث عن تعدديه قطبيه او
ثنائيه قطبيه كذلك بوتين في موسكو يتحدث
عن وجوب تغير هذا النظام الاول العالم
من مصالح
البلديه هناك كذلك نظره من الهند كقوه
صاعده نظره من الدول الاخرى يعني لكن بعيد
له نظره ربما اجتمع من خلاله في مارس 2022
دكتور اذا كنت تتذكر هذا التاريخ في لقاء
كان شهيرا اعتقد في مائده مستديره جمع
فيها قاده جنرال موتورز ابل امازون قال
فيها ان الان هو وقت تتحول فيه الامور نحن
نتجه الى ذلك سيكون هناك نظام عالمي جديد
وعلينا ان نتولى قيادته وخلال ذلك علينا
ان نوحد بقيه العالم الحر
ما هو النظام العالمي الجديد من مفهوم
امريكا وبايدن تحديدا والى اي مدى هذا
النظام يمكن ان يتفق او يتقاطع او يتعارض
مع مصالح الدول الاخرى نتحدث عن السعوديه
تحديدا بالمنطق من وجهه نظري نعم
في امريكا شوف في امريكا في يعني طرفين
في القياده الفكريه والقياده السياسيه في
طرف وهو المهيمن للاسف الان يريد عداء او
يخلق عدو من الصين يعني ان يعيد ان يعيد
تاريخ الحرب البارده وان يبدل الاتحاد
السوفيتي بالصين انه الصين هو الان العدو
الكبير ولازم انه كل طاقات امريكا
العسكريه واستراتيجيه والايديولوجيه كلها
ان تتجه
لعداء الصين او لمعاداه الصين انا انا خطر
كبير في هذا الفكر وفي هذا المنحه
والاتجاه اولا الصين علاقتها بامريكا
مختلفه عن ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي لانه في
علاقات اقتصاديه يعني كبيره من بين
الطرفين ومن الصعب جدا انه خلق الشرخ هذا
بين البلدين
اضافه ولكن في نفس الوقت هذا يصب في مصالح
كبيره امريكيه ان كانت في المصالح عسكريه
مصالح صناعيه الى اخره بايدن من محبي لي
هذا الفكر العدائي اتجاه الصين ترامب لم
يكن كذلك يعني في عداء تجاه الصين ولكن في
كمان ممكن انه يتعامل معها
فانا ارى انه المملكه والدول الاخرى مثل
الاعنف السلوك امريكا تحاول
بالقوانين بالحرب التجاريه بغيرها من
الامور اليس كذلك كان في صحيح لانه لانه
هو لانه هو شاف انه الصين كانت بتاخذ كل
كل العماله يعني كل كل الوظائف من امريكا
الى الصين بس لكن عدائه كان عداء اقتصادي
موعده ايديولوجي او عداء يعني هو ما عنده
عداء تجاه الصين لاسباب ايديولوجيه اوكي
او عسكريه واضح هو يريد ان يعيد كل كل
الوظائف هذه اللي راحت الى الصين ويعيدها
الى امريكا مصلحه السعوديه
دكتور تكون فيها امريكا والصين وروسيا
وغيرها من الدول
هو يعني هو بايدن التعدديه القطبيه عند
انه في دول في عالم ديموقراطي وفي عالم
استبداد في عالم يعني اوتوكراطي هم يسمونه
هذا يعني هذا
يعني التفسير للعالم يعني ما هو قائم على
على واقع لانه في دول
مثل ما نقول تركيا او الهند هي شبه
استبداديه ولكن هي حليفه امريكا فيعني
التصوير هذا للعالم يعني تبسيط جدا لمصالح
امريكا وما بيخدم مصالح امريكا وفي دول
مثل مثل المملكه مثلا
ما عليهم ان يختاروا بين الصين وامريكا
يريدون ان ان يكون لهم علاقه مع البلدين
مش بس المملكه يعني في دول اخرى حتى في
اسرائيل في مصر في تركيا في الهند
فرض
المنظومه هذه منظومه انه الصين هو العدو
الاول والاخير
انا اعتقد انه خطر جدا على امريكا وعلى
العالم سؤالي لك حول الاخير حول السودان
دكتور في الوقت الذي بدانا نشعر فيه بحاله
من من التهدئه في المنطقه بعد المصالحات
اللي جرت اشتعلت السودان بشكل مفاجئ مع
انه من كان يتحكم في كل المسارات خلال في
السودان المتازمه اصلا يعني هي الولايات
المتحده والرباعيه الدوليه يعني بشكل كبير
وكانت تستطيع بالفعل ان تتعامل مع مع
البرهان ممثله للجيش مع القوه السياسيه
المدنيه وكذلك مع حميدتي الطرفي الصراع
يعني فبالتالي هل من مصلحه امريكيه في
اشعال الوضع في السودان في المنطقه
لا اعتقد انا بصراحه انا ارى انه مصلحه
امريكا هي قريبه جدا من مصلحه المملكه وهي
انه تهدئه المنطقه وعدم اشعال الحروب في
المنطقه وحتى بصراحه هو نفس هذه كمان
مصلحه الصين يعني الصين تريد ان
النفط من الخليج ان ياتي اليها ومن دون اي
حروب او مشاكل وكذا انا ارى انه في تقاطع
بصراحه بالمصالح
بين امريكا وبين المملكه اكيد يعني في
موضوع السودان وفي المنطقه عموما وهو
الاستقرار
وعدم اشعال الحروب وارى انه اضافه الى ذلك
انه الصين في المنطقه بخلاف مثلا تايوان
موضوع تايوان هنا لا يتقاطع بين في
المصالح ولكن في المنطقه في تقاطع بين
مصالح امريكا والصين وهو الاستقرار
وتخليص من من كل القوى والدول التي تريد
ان تزعزع
الحاله الامنيه في المنطقه ومنها اكيد
ايران ان شاء الله نشوفك قريب في الرياض
شكرا جزيلا لك على تواجدك معي في سؤال
شكرا عزيزي شكرا
دائما يمكنكم متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر
ومشاهده هذه الحلقه والاستماع اليها نشاهد
على العربيه
[موسيقى]